hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Anthony Elba
we're gonna watch the trailer for a
little independent film called Avengers
age of Ultron damn that noise outside
this is supposed to be a perfect video
actually know what it adds to the raw
authenticity Avengers 1 did you like it
I did like it I liked it a lot of
surprisingly it's one of my favorite
films one of the best movie experiences
I've ever had I had a big smile on my
face the whole time I'm not I'm not a
Marvel fan usually but that one had me
for some reason that and guarding its
the galaxy let's see what the hype is
all about oh god this is so exciting I'm
gonna show you something beautiful
everyone screaming for mercy we want to
protect the world but you don't want it
to change
puppets tangled strings strings
it's the end the end of the path I
started us on nothing lasts forever
[ __ ]
Wow
there are no strings on me
did Ironman become a bad guy what
happened I don't know that's what we got
to find out for but yes this one I match
Wow so much to talk about this is gonna
be amazing
every sequel goes darker I mean that's
that's the key ingredient right go
darker yeah the darkness actually seems
to really be felt here like the Ultron's
truly seems menacing not ballet seem
look exciting that there was a random
ballet scene like oh my god like man I
mean it's it's like so cool just to see
them all in the same movie again I mean
it's not like the same kind of like new
feeling is when you saw it for the first
time but it looks like they really did
like amp up the game they'll app they up
the ante quite a bit enough and I want
to understand why Iron Man and Hulk are
fighting and I kind of don't care I
could just watch the fight scene and be
like that looks cool maybe they weren't
actually fighting maybe hook was just
losing his mind and threw a car at Iron
Man and they just put that in there to
make a stink that we're gonna fight each
other well no they say he like punched
him towards the end but he's just like
losing his mind because Hulk yeah I mean
that might be happening I don't know we
don't know though I'm not an aficionado
when it comes to comic books that [ __ ]
looks amazing yeah when that happened I
like foot the ball or whatever that
means what I don't know I'm really
interested in seeing the Quicksilver
portrayal I know he's in Days of Future
past so it's interesting to see like
this is gonna be a different take on
Quicksilver and then when there's a
bunch of robots at one point Dan this
shit's gonna be intense how do you feel
about the CGI the better Ultron
yeah Ultron I like it I think the
cinematography balances out well because
it's like the right light that's what I
noticed like the key to a lot of these
like visual effects is good
cinematography you know he does look
menacing is way scarier than Loki that's
really scary
well Loki's like a fun bad guy this
guy's just scary no he's like evil he it
seems like he'll be the Joker of the but
he actually seems like a good actually
seems like a good bad guy for a change
like the bad guy in guardians of the
galaxy was just like generic bad whereas
he seems like really menacingly bad here
no it seems like a detailed actual
villain it seems like he has an actual
is not just a robot like he actually has
a personality about him and it seems
like he has his own thoughts and
emotions which is really cool to see - I
mean that trailer just teases a lot of
like horrible things that are going to
happen you see like Mark Ruffalo in the
snow at one point the Shi
is broken in half and Kesten america is
always getting knocked down though to
get back up at the end of fight again I
will say though after a Winter Soldier I
like Captain America a lot more this is
Batman
I just pissed off a lot of you by
drinking this cup I liked Iron Man's
[ __ ] head more this big guy is what it
kind of looked like the big hero six
super hero wending he's a little bit
when he's like geared up but a much
cooler more menacing version yeah I want
to see what all the conflict is going on
here like the word just randomly picks
up Tony Stark by the threw it at one
point but you know what was really good
about the first one was that it had so
much going on yet it didn't feel like it
would lost track of the story was
telling it didn't feel compact right
whereas a lot of people's complaints
about spider-man 3 with Tobey Maguire
and the recent Spider Man was like it
was just convoluted and all over the
place
I'm really like trepidatious about this
cuz I got a lot packed into this one
trailer I'm like is this gonna be as
concise and clean as the first one was
well I just trust Joss would you guys
shut up I'm trying to film here I really
trust Joss Whedon though because he
knows how to like take care of an
ensemble he knows how to give just
efficient amount of character each time
you know so there's only a few more
characters in this it's not like they
bombarded it with a lot more characters
right any circuses in this oh yeah
that's what Andy Serkis was an ending
kong Smeagol stupid fact ventures I am
you're doing the wrong well it looks
like they [ __ ] up New York a lot again
which is really cool to see something
New York does not get enough destruction
in movies no no no no we need to take it
every sin on New York yeah because we
relate to it as an American audience
right we understand I don't think we've
destroyed New York enough no not in real
life and not in movies nope good I was
taking it too far
no it was too funny if Seth MacFarlane
can make jokes about it I can't I'm on
the same status quo
similarly Farley I just want the humor
to still be there cuz that's part of
what me the First Avenger so great was
how funny it was so if the humor is
still there within these care because
that humor brought the characters to
life I'm hoping it still has that same
touch and they don't get too serious
about it
it looks pretty serious and uh looks
really serious but I hope that like
escalates into that it doesn't start off
as the darkest [ __ ] movie of all time
there wasn't a one funny moment in that
with the sweaty stork it was like this
is the end of everything I've done yeah
it's just a trailer actually there
there's a bunch of rumors that Avengers
3 will mainly have a new cast like a new
set of care they're gonna kill everybody
off in this one that'd be cool
and then to be concluded what will we do
and in the ballet people are gonna come
back with superpowers you and the
[ __ ] baby you know what this might be
better just based off how epic it is
thank you guys for recommending that
trailer I only got like a thousand
comments about it right when the trailer
was released and I wanted to make sure I
was in the right mood to watch this if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects Anthony my
broseph Joseph or as I call him the
Quentin Tarantino out of the from dusk
till dawn relationship okay sure great
Anthony Alba channel short films movie
reviews you know run in the family
that's how we do it
Ultron hey what do you know he wants a
shout out please
Ultron I don't want to give you a
shout-out you look like an [ __ ] in my
opinion I saw what you're doing to my
favorite homeboys and you know what
they're all gonna kick your ass cuz
you're a [ __ ] sentient yes I know
exactly what that word means and I am
responding to that scary
well Ultron is um like I say he's a
[ __ ] high flyers tag team can I get a
shout-out friend may brock kid perv dude
well my friend um first off am I your
friend yes yes I guess we're friends
make sure we can be lovers brah
I don't wear bras my boobs have got a
smaller kid I want a kid one day perv
that's fair dude yeah
no no per dude everything else I agree
with brah kid per not dude well brother
my penis tends to differ what is high
fliers tag team exactly I mean are you
guys like tag team in like low fliers
like you guys are like just taking care
of one low flyer at a time double stuff
you know what I mean huh I don't think
they worry about the low fliers I think
they're all up here and they'll all
right you're taking I don't know I don't
know if that means me
double penetration joke completely
original gamer hey Ryan can you react a
VHS viral Gator already reacted Gator
Gator Mardon sub [ __ ] you want
to go to trailer reaction war but can
you it's awesome plus can you give me a
shout-out please original gamer you are
the first one to ever play a game and I
am proud of you for doing that
thank you for being the first is he is
like 97 years old original gamer it was
one man by himself in the 1910s
I don't know critic open no games had
ever existed everyone thought he was
crazy little did they know he was on the
cusp of a revolution
what are doing we're just saying I think
you're taking over my channel brother